start by finding the beach in in hot oil
seasoning as you go
this is a very economical cut of beef as
it slow cooks it also makes the most
delicious gravy as the marrow thickens
and flavors of source
in the same pan so they chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots sliced celery
peeled and chopped ginger and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine and the juice of
an orange listed glazing the pan adding
incredible depth of flavor pour in
chicken stock season and simmer for an
hour and 20 minutes
this dish is brilliant finish with
gremolata a dry Italian salsa made with
chopped herbs simply chopped parsley and
garlic together and mixing the zest of
an orange or lemon when the beef is
cooked rich unctuous
and beautifully tender scatter over the
lovely fresh gremolata simple satisfied
and crammed full of wonderful tastes and
textures delicious well beautiful all
that has reduced down as amazing nice
stir through chopped mint pile onto
toasted bread and finally for a lovely
salty tang crumble over some creamy feta
cheese